when the uh Kentucky Democrat Governor
Basher uh during the coid lockdowns
decided to let a bunch of criminals out
of prison turns out that those criminals
that he let out of prison they they went
on and committed more crimes impossible
this I mean how could you can't blame
Andy Basher here right how could he have
possibly seen it coming that people who
are known for committing a lot of crimes
if you let them out of their punishment
and you just set them free in society
they're going to commit more crimes how
could any modern liberal who recognizes
that no one is personally responsible
for their crimes and actually it's
society's fault and the prison
industrial complex is a terrible form of
Oppression and slavery and actually we
just need to give people hugs and let
them free and let them be there they
don't even have free will we can't
anyway who could have
guessed normal people is who could have
guessed